Adam Levine it did it doctor did it that
I'm so happy to meet you that's happy
I'm having to do so why did you want to
work with a brand like L'Oreal Paris why
not um it's it's cool it's cool to be
part of the men's side of it to not not
often you see that kind of thing so it
was a unique kind of look so I was into
it mm-hmm
you're a man with so much on the go I
mean from your career your growing
family how do you make time for
self-care I somehow figure it out I
don't know how it I don't know how it
all works you know but uh yeah I know
it's important to take care of yourself
as you're doing all this stuff in fact
that's the most important thing if you
can't take care of yourself then what's
the point in doing it you're on tour
right now for red pill Blues how has
touring changed this time around since
the first time you guys went on tour huh
well the first time I went on tour we
were in a van and we were an opening act
and we'd we just you know slept in the
same 15 passenger van for a couple years
so the difference is substantial Pharma
far more luxurious now so I'm very happy
that is the case cuz it's a it's a grind
out there on a van but we paid our dues
you know we did it we did it that way
for a long time clubs or the borrower's
turn into clubs to theaters turn into
arenas it's crazy
big big progression big evolution
they're big time thank God I'm really
thankful for that I'm sorry that
mattress the last time we spoke to you
you said that you didn't care about the
radio charts and then girls like you
slay the chyme weren't you like no I
mean I don't know those hey maybe that's
a simplified yeah
you caring about it is fine come on I
don't think that I care about it when we
have a song up yeah I don't care about
it when we don't but yeah it's amazing
to have a big song on the charges dream
stuff you know yes we you know in vision
and our wildest fantasies is having time
success on the radio is so cool it's
just us on the radio and then you have
another Grammy nomination this is your
13th one oh yes does the excitement
swing every time yeah absolutely being
good being nominated for a Grammy will
always be an honor
yeah so that's just it's amazing just
getting the nominations enough it's just
so cool we're really happy with that mr.
fun it's exciting this this far into it
there still be getting a criminal and
she's still doing it
Thanks Grammys good job and I know you
have a new competition series the song
land yes it's really good
and it's actually you know I think that
every kind of angle has been covered
when it comes to singing competitions
but this isn't one of those this is a
strictly a songwriting competition but
it's it's really real and that's why I
was really excited to get involved with
it because it's it's a real look into
how or into what the process of writing
a song is about and and the kind of the
grind of that whole world and something
that was not really my universe until
relatively recently till we started
writing songs with other people in doing
co-writes and things like that but it's
such an amazing look into what it takes
to make a song to make a song work and
to get it out into the world
so I'm really just happy about how
authentic it is and it's it's I think
gonna be a huge show because it's never
you know it's always exciting to be part
of something that you feel that you
genuinely feel isn't out there it
doesn't exist at least not done in this
way so I'm a very high hopes for it I
hope you know everybody loves it I love
it yeah I'm a fan
well Adam I'm really happy that you are
you know promoting self care through
L'Oreal I think that more men need to
worry about their aesthetics just for
dating life for me to live well things
life I think new I think we've come a
long way I think that we I think that US
guys if we've started to figure out that
taking care of ourselves is not any less
masculine there we go for a minute of it
maybe people for a long time you know
people that shunned the idea but I think
we've embraced it as a as a culture
these guys you're making it cool hopes
up yeah well thank you clearly I'm
wearing sweat pants and a sweater but
your skin is bright my skin looks good I
appreciate your time this is really fun
thank guys brings me nice to meet you
you